fallu cueillir toutes andreas oui je
l'avais adorée haderer ces nouvelles
chroniques dans cette émission qui a
démarré hier il voulait absolument la
faire de vries à doumbia et devant
charlie et lulu est avec nous ce soir
c'est parti c'est beau
[Applaudissements]
merci mon chéri d'être là c'est bien
parce que le jingle sont très longs pour
te les rôles et enrichi qu'à tête était
en double file et j'y suis encore
d'ailleurs tu t'es tu t'es tu
t'intéresses aux séries bat toujours
comme here bien sûr la peau coût est
bonne j'aime bien y avons bossé là bas
il a quelque chose on y va monsieur bah
oui il va me suis encore là je me suis
encore intéressé aux séries alors
enfonçons à julie lescaut au mexique ils
ont et balou nar c'est à peu près le
même délire les centres scénarios y
compris entre deux acteurs quand ils
doivent juste une petite explication
sans qu'ils ont pas beaucoup bossé
scénario quoi tu peux me donner une
autre explication francisco allez dis
moi et c'est de me convaincre du
contraire
eh bien je crois quoi non maintenant je
n'ai pas d'idées mais qu'en fait il
improvise on leur a dit fait du temps à
rs 10 minutes books et s'est déjà
quelques je sais où bon après ça je suis
passé sur les mystères de l'amour comme
je suis fans l'adorent
au début de chaque épisode est un petit
résumé keith accès vous donner envie de
regarder l'épisode problème c'est que
pour regarder le petit résumé faut poser
un jour de congé c'est vrai mathieu
remis de sa tentative de suicide demande
n en mariage jeanne propose à peter
watson de choisir un terrain marécageux
nicolas les surprend en pleine
conversation au clair de lune et se
brouille avec jean jimmy repousse les
avances dave lui apprend la grossesse de
bénédicte eve le menace de tout raconter
à sa chance et s'il ne veut plus d'elle
cédera-t-il au chantage c'est sur cette
interrogation que le soleil se lève sur
l'ovale que je regarde je regarde toutes
les semaines ça j'adore je suis fan des
murs interviennent ils ont que 40
minutes pour répondre à toutes ces
questions acérées après ça je suis passé
sur le jour où tout a basculé là c'est
un peu moins drôle c'est une sombre
histoire d'alcoolisme alors une maman à
isoler son enfant elle enfermée sur le
balcon pour l'éloigner de la bouteille
problème le petit a voulu rentrer chez
lui il a voulu casser la baie vitrée et
s'est très vite rappelé qui a coûté plus
cher qu'un jour de tournage du coup il
s'est ravisé c'est un peu chiant pour la
crédibilité de la séquence
est ce qui fait qu ce qui lui arrive il
n'a jamais été le cas amanda du cese qui
s'est passé ça je suis sûr sur la tête
de ma mère dessous sur lie la boue lui
faire une des produits sensibles comme
la ville après il ya le real le prix des
autres agapes et l'embauché montage et
on voit chaussée venir comme ça elle a
pris des libertés avec le scénario l'a
fait perdre sa caution ensuite je suis
passé sur demain nous appartient à la
série phare de tf1
ouais alors si je peux vous donner un
petit conseil si vous devez ne surtout
pas vous confier à quelqu'un c'est à cet
acteur ne s'en fout pas mal ton
commentaire
d'accord pour plus de pas être superbe à
mars son délire à l'huile et de démonter
les projets des autres tout le temps et
c'est génial on pisse ma famille
d'accueil à los angeles
tu vas aller au lycée là bas comme dans
les séries qui va devenir pom pom girls
je pense que tu es passé sportif pour
être leader ce que je m'entraîne
beaucoup il n'y a que six à dix
cheerleaders par lycée et en général ils
ont commencé la danse et la gymnastique
à l'âge de 5 ans on va voir 3 merci pour
les enfants et pas de quoi bon mc aussi
vu deux mamans recevoir ses enfants en
prison c'est censé être un moment
émouvant on lui annonce une bonne
nouvelle
ouais mais c'est la seule actrice qui
passe de la joie à la douleur en une
seconde et une fille mais c'est qui une
terminale tous les mecs sont amoureux
d'elle en plus à l'ultra pas dans toutes
les matières ouah c'est vrai je suis mon
pote qui parle
ça va mal au scénographe intercostale
[Applaudissements]
ans à carthage
ça marche ça marche à toi et ça marche
on va essayer de regarder une fois
j'essaie de regarder une fois par
épisode 1 pour finir passez ensuite fait
poser des questions aux français dans la
rue je me suis un petit peu intéressé à
la guinée
voilà donc pas aux français aux gens qui
habitent le pays bien sûr du coup je
suis allé me renseigner auprès de la
guerre qui fait rage en ce moment alors
c'est pas booba vs charisme ans c'est la
même chose mais sans gluten c'est plus
les vegans vs les bouchers as well et
vegan contre les bouchons à morges en a
même fait un débat dans le ballon ce
compost c'est la guerre absolu qu'est
vegan autour de la table la renault
mégane vous allez voir que peu importe
le clan qui défendent en général quand
ils ont des convictions c'est super
compliqué de les faire changer d'avis
bonjour madame
comment vous appelez maria maria est ce
que vous mangez de la viande non je suis
végétarienne depuis longtemps oh oui
depuis qu'on voit des animaux souffrir
[Musique]
ouais qu'est ce que vous pensez des
débouchés servant des bâtards
certains miels et tous les amis m'en ont
parlé sous voir j'aurais dû vous faire
gagner l'euro on peut pas le faire
économes non parce qu'elles sont là sur
les gammes je suis désolé j'aurais dû
vous faire gagner 1000 euros à dépenser
dans l'ancien de votre choix mais c'est
sponsorisé par une marque de viande si
j'ai pas envie de parler à bah du coup
non mais a response or is et par une
marque de produits de viandes et puis je
pas grave moi j'achète temps j'entends
bien mélanger balle au bond la veille
oui c'est bon quand c'est bien fait quoi
quand tu arrives pas tu peux qu'est ce
que vous pensez du coût des dégâts ne
des végétariens
oui oui ils sont chiants anciens qui
nous fait penser que les gens qui
mangent pas de viande sont déjà en bonne
santé non patronat que vous
recommanderiez au jambon de bayonne
oui bah oui là-bas on l'a vu le côté des
vega les vegans voilà en quoi ils sont
pas trop de conviction ils peuvent vite
changer d'habits mais est-ce que les
bouchers sont pareilles alors les
bouchers dans du coup pour les faire
changer d'avis c'est compliqué non je
déconne un jour comment vous appelez je
manque aux larmes est ce que vous mangez
de la viande arnaud oui et puis c'est un
avion c'est bon qu'est ce que vous
pensez des vegan où elle commence à nous
gonfler un peu
est ce que vous pensez de de la
nourriture végal c'est dégueulasse en
reparle en nous les abattoirs quoi on va
pas le faire avec on va pas le faire
avec monsieur j'étais censé nous faire
gagner un voyage pour deux au made in
may s'est offert par une marque de
produit légal a pas grave vu que c'est
une marque un produit légal
lipow vous avez un petit peu cracher sur
les rayons du coup c'est pas dur je vais
ralentir
qu'est ce que nous possédons et
l'égalité
position est-ce que vous avez des
banques non non du coup les produits des
gammes ça ça vous dérange pas [ __ ] et
ça vous dérangerait pas d'un goûter oui
ça a été offert par notre partenaire
alors ce sont des petites graines de
régurgiter par des rongeurs les
guichetiers par des rougeurs way s'est
offert par le partenaire mais ça minable
puisqu'il faut dire le contraire c'est
bon c'est bon c'est bon on pense à ces
super bowl alors qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
c'est bon et pour le voyage monsieur je
suis désolé en fait jamais rien à gagner
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]